au revoir
et la mâchoire inférieure du requin s'est
coincée dans le nez de la planche
et alors qu'il traversait et se retournait hors
de l'eau, son nez m'a frappé sur le
côté de la tête
mais mon bras gauche s'est avancé et sa
mâchoire supérieure s'est serrée sur mon  bras et pris au piège
qu'entre l'autre côté de la planche, cela
m'a emmené au fond de l'océan
et euh,
nous avons nagé un peu, nous nous sommes en quelque
sorte écartés l'un de l'autre et avons
finalement obtenu mon bras libre
ce n'était pas avant  vous savez probablement que 10
secondes après s'être assis sur ma planche
et avoir
regardé comme si mon bras était complètement
déchiré et qu'il y avait des os qui
pendaient et j'ai réalisé alors que j'avais
en fait été attaqué par un requin
[Musique]
donc du
monde entier dans  contact et
ils passent une bonne journée ou ne
passent pas une bonne journée
et donc je peux partager les triomphes
ainsi que les mauvais moments
[Musique]
donc
tellement bon que vous avez des gens qui ont
été  mordu par des alligators et mordu par
des hippopotames euh donc c'est ouvert
aux gens qui ont
juste besoin de quelqu'un pour dire que j'y suis
allé fait ça
ouais regardez le club de vélo qu'ils ont
créé
est tout simplement fantastique car je ne m'en étais pas rendu compte  il
y avait tellement de gens autour et
ça l'a ouvert à un
groupe international de personnes
[Musique]
vous